tonight's padres starting pitcher east
county's joe musgrove making his first
start for the team he grew up cheering
for
an 02 to walker
and a swing and a miss struck him out
first k for joe musgrove
made him look bad with the first slider
why not put him away with another slider
and the musgrove family oh yeah
they're loving it you can see a pattern
here joe musko is trying to go hard down
and in
down and away at the strike zone to
peralta
swings at the 1-2 and strikes out
muskel with back-to-back k's two in the
first padres are coming up picture for
the diamondbacks is the left-hander
caleb smith acquired for the marlins
last year in the starling martial
tatis leads off and drops down to third
good start for caleb smith with that
slider
and
smith was a marlin before he was a
diamondback traded at the trade deadline
a year ago
machado opposite field does it have
enough smith back at the wall it's gone
[Music]
first hit of the year is an opposite
field home run and it puts padres on top
one to nothing
no need to sweat it
man he's gonna be manny
nice easy swing like we've seen so many
times before
going the opposite way first and second
two down
huss on kim coming up so here's kim
making his first major league start
kim sends it through the left side into
left field to base hit myers being waved
around he'll score padres have a
two-nothing lead ha
kim with his first mlb hit
and rbi
now they're loaded for victor caratini
who had three rv guys on opening day not
in game number three there's the
fastball and caleb smith gets an
enormous strikeout
and strands three but it's san diego who
takes the early lead david smith leading
it off here for the d-backs
he may have gone yeah he did
strikes out three k's in a row for joe
musgrove
two down in the second inning four in a
row retired by muskrobe and here's josh
van meter
that is strike three gets him anyway
four strikeouts for joe musgrove
two-nothing padres after an inning and a
half
two on two down and will myers coming up
that's a third walk served up by caleb
smith
myers lines it into left center field
for a base head
fernando tossy jr is going to score
trying to score from first as familiar
comes to throw he will
padres take a four-nothing lead
they work the count
they hit
they run
they're aggressive
they add on
off to a good start here tonight steven
vogt to lead off
swinging a miss and he strikes out
steven boat that's five k's for muscaro
here's the pitcher caleb smith
oh two swing a miss oh boy joe musgrove
made very quick work of him another
slider another swing and a miss six
strikeouts in three innings nine in a
row retired by musgrove one down here in
the fourth ending brings up christian
walker
to left field and deep mateo going back
onto the track he lifts and makes the
pitch up against the wall
jorge mateo
so much going on here timed it perfectly
jorge
okay
and a tip of the calf from the
right-hander joe musgrove
taking away extra bases
strikeout victim in the first inning
let's see if that's a backdoor curveball
strike three call
seventh strikeout for joe musgrove he's
retired 11 in a row with two strikes
they shift three guys over on the left
side of the infield against tatis here's
the o2 and fernando grounds it into that
left side rojas the middleman has it low
throw eats walker up and tatis is on his
way to second base he'll get there
without a throw oh my goodness
about as routine as can be for the
shortstop rojas
really had plenty of time to get his
legs underneath him and make that throw
to first base but elected to throw on
the move instead looks like christian
walker got the worst of that one at
first base
he
yeah he took one he's got a shiner right
there right under the eye
he's got plenty of time right there to
gather himself and make a good throw but
instead he kind of sidearms one in the
dirt that took a real nasty hop and came
up and fought christian walker
underneath the left eye i think he's
coming out of the game looks like ted
barrett the crew chief went over there
to check in with tory lavillo
and walker will have to leave the game
with a bad throw by josh rohan somewhat
of a gap in right center field right now
for manny machado he's been taking it
the other way
and a grounder this time into center
field
fernando tatis jr is being waved around
he'll score run number five of the night
for the padres many machado drives in
another
full count to will now
with two outs and manny machado with
first base
channel goes and myers drives what a
deep left peralta back and it is off the
wall
machado keeps on going around third will
try and score
he will and the padres take a
six-nothing lead
second double the night for will myers
and the padres add on to the sixth
this ball had a chance there's the
hanging breaking ball oh right down the
middle inner third and will thinks he's
got it
oh maybe a couple feet
from going over now
manny's eyeing it bobby dickerson
sends him home
nothing like adding on two down meyer is
at second base now jay chronoworth
to left field down the line peralta on
the run and he dives can't get it it's
behind him myers will score cutterworth
in the second base got an rbi double and
the padres have a seven nothing lead
as we look at ryan weathers 2019 in fort
wayne lowe a ball 22 starts
to me he's a modern day santana high
school left-hander terry forster
payoff pitch to eduardo
escobar swing and a miss he struck him
out
so weathers has it cleaned one two three
seventh and seventh inning stretch with
the padres on top seven to nothing
[Applause]
this one is the second
second for one on to first for two and
that is the ball game
4-3 in the dp that wraps it up
and the padres have shut out the arizona
diamondbacks in game three of the series
they win it seven to nothing